Next up, Tweet the Press.
It looks like angrier Lorax,
Donald Trump,
-might be the first president...
-(laughter)
-JAMES: Oh, God. -of the
great-again States of America
to avoid the media
by holding press conferences
solely on social media.
It's like his own weekly
Tweet the Press.
He even explained why he tweets
in a tweet he tweeted yesterday
on Twitter.
"If the press would cover me
accurately and honorably,
I would have far less reason
to 'tweet.'" Quote, unquote.
"Sadly, I don't know
if that will ever happen!"
Wha...? Meow!
Take that, the press!
So, comedians, I want to know
what Donald Trump will say
on the next Tweet the Press.
-(bird tweeting)
-(news show music playing)
Eh, that was... that was all
the rest of our year's budget.
(laughter)
-Mike Lawrence.
-Does anyone know how to run
the world's
most powerful government?
-Asking for a friend.
-Yeah, all right.